[Music]
I'm just gonna ask you a tough question
right oh here we go
um there what's up questions like on a
hot seat over here you kind of are well
there are some and I will say again it's
because people loved seeing you guys
together so much and I'm knowing you
both you're both amazing people yeah
there are we definitely appreciated that
for sure we loved all the support yeah
and I think people want both of you to
find love and people love seeing you
with Ken's and char but there are some
photos of you and Amanda from last night
your arm is around her you guys are
kissing uh-huh what does that mean I
don't haven't seen these photos are you
sure they're not a photoshopped or
something I'm a hundred percent sure you
know we're trying to deal with stuff in
a more private manner and everything
right now obviously and we just kind of
want people to respect that and
especially because it's a tough
situation with the kids and we don't
want to kind of fully dive into anything
because we're thinking about them as
well this is the first time I've seen
her in a while when I came out this week
I came for one of my friends events and
I decided I did some other stuff while I
was here and we ran into each other and
stuff and you know we just had long
conversations we there were
conversations that needed to be had and
we had a great dinner and everything
like that
kissing next question it was a good
evening we had a good time I mean
whenever we're together especially
outside of the show and outside of all
the drama that's that's shown and all
that kind of stuff it's always been a
good relationship it was just so many
outside forces and outside factors that
got involved when we were together after
the show it was unfortunate for a little
bit I am single right now so you know
I'm traveling a little bit I'm having
some fun and doing some things and
enjoying some people meeting people
you